sometimes from a colleague or a client  you will hear an expression or a concept  that you don't know yet and many people  will just ask I don't know this what  does this mean can you please explain  this to me and of course this implies  that you have no idea about what this is  about you might be perceived as not  really knowledgeable so next time this  happens to you try instead to say  something like what does this expression  mean to you what do you understand with  this term because this implies that  actually you know what this expression  means but you even have this higher  level understanding that sometimes  different people understand different  things with the same expression so you  want to clarify it and this takes away  this notion that you have no idea what  you're talking about